uh jamal murray
went off went smoove off and his coach
mike colon said this after the game
i think what i've seen from jamal this
year aside from the growth defensively
which has been tremendous and and just
i'm so proud of him in that regard but
now to be i know every night what i'm
getting from jamal
you know last year it was we knew what
we were getting from the cola what kind
of game will jamal have that's no longer
the case we have two superstars we have
two superstars and nicola and jamal and
a lot of other really good young
talented players behind them
superstar mike is that fax jamal murray
a superstar no
no
no it's not a fact i mean he's a
talented
he's a talented player who has the
ability to go off every now and i mean i
shouldn't say every now and then because
that
seems going off a lot in these playoffs
he's like seems like i'm marginalizing
him i'm not i'm not doing that
like he what he did in game seven
against the clippers
big got to have a situation he's over 40
points in a game seven so he can do that
and that's not a surprise but
a superstar
is a player you want to talk about know
it when you see it a superstar is
someone where the coach doesn't have to
stand there at a press conference and
say it and then you talk about it on a
show the next day to ask if the coach is
right
like a soup right a superstar one
definition that's one that we're missing
i like that there it is that's one of
that's like the fourth definition right
there
if if jamal murray were a superstar
everybody would have looked at uh mike
malone last night and said yeah of
course yeah right why are you saying
that
yeah well maybe well well well maybe
mike malone is telling you michael holly
that he has arrived and it's time to
start calling him the superstar maybe
that's what the purpose we'll see
we'll see usually i mean something
something usually happens there where
everybody can just
see it there's some turn maybe it's a
maybe it's these playoffs
because i think denver
now i'm about to make people in denver
mad but hey so be it
um
denver knows what it's like to be down
three games to one they did it in their
first two series they're about to do it
this series too because
they're about to go down okay they're
about to go down they're about to go
down 3-1 to the lakers say so and then
we'll see what happens so maybe that's
it maybe we see the superstar superstar
jamal murray once again back against the
wall and brings his team back for the
third time in the postseason from a 3-1
deficit because i think we need to see
more i like that nuggets i like the
nuggets a lot
but i don't think they're quite ready i
think they're a year away
from from representing the western
conference for a while i think they're
one year one year that's it is that is
that a bad thing to say we might we do
we do no it's not a bad it's not a bad
thing to say but basically they're in
2022 games
based on the last two games we're one
week away from you having to take that
back because based on the last two games
they're going to win this series they'll
just just from what we're seeing right
now the way the lakers may be leading
this series but they are not in control
of this series if if that makes sense
they may be
saying it doesn't la favorites home it
doesn't sound like you gotta
a lot of times it's not about making
sense and it's certainly not about
talking loud it's the authority with
which you deliver your take doesn't have
to be right that have to be accurate you
just got to deliver it a certain way
this is just the right delivery okay but
no seriously um
he's playing like a superstar how's that
because the orlando bubble
is what is the best we could do for the
biggest stage right now it's still the
nba playoffs it's still the western
conference finals it's not on the road
it's not the usual set of circumstances
but it is the only place he can prove
himself and it is the place where we
judge superstars the most and that's
what you do in the postseason in this
postseason two 50-point games four
40-point games five 30-point games 26.6
points 48 from three
and six and a half assists yeah a game
just to put out the numbers that he's
putting up but a superstar see this is
why i'm going to agree with you and say
no he's not a superstar even though he's
putting on a superstar like performance
is
everybody it's almost like it's like top
five conversations like mvp
conversations like top ten everybody
can't be in it and if you start calling
any and everybody a superstar no
disrespect to jamal murray then it just
waters down the definition it's as
though
we do not
we're not satisfied with star what's
wrong with this player
i'm okay with
everybody can't be a superstar let me
just run down these names to you real
quick just real quick
mitchell george paul tatum and b butler
jokic dane doncic kawhi a.d hardin
lebron giannis kyrie katie steph clay
draymond draymond on tnt somebody might
call him a superstar giveaways
accomplished russ and here's what i mean
the reason i throw those names out let
me take let me focus on paul george
once upon a time not long ago when
people wore pajamas and live life slow
there might have been people who called
paul george a superstar
crazy ask people right now that's what
they call paul george a superstar so
here's the other part about a superstar
michael holly once you bestow it upon
somebody you can't just take it back
it's there so yeah it's a supreme court
justice like appointment it's lifetime
you can't just take it back me like oh
he was a superstar last night but not
anymore yeah so we gotta be careful
you